hey Peter Roomba senior editor at Wired
here with from across the stage to your
right Eric Andre hosting the Eric Andre
show on Adult Swim Hannibal Buress
stand-up phenomenon in his own right
television writer and also collaborate
on Eric Andre show and Derrick Beckles
of the upcoming late-night companion
show to the Eric Andre show how package
is that correct that is correct you have
the shoes of weirdness you're gonna have
to feel coming after the Eric Andre show
which shoes a witness there's you guys
in the holler will you compete to be the
weirdest live-action show so where does
live-action Children's Hospital gets
really weird before we get to the new
scene of an undertone tell us a little
bit about how package because this is
this is the newcomer to Adult Swim's
late-night block right yeah I'm excited
about it it's an entertainment show
basically I'm doing an Entertainment
Tonight type show like in the vibe of
extra and ie Hollywood and Access
Hollywood and all that but we're kind of
doing a parallel universe thing so
pretty much nobody in the show they
oversee you'll know anything about but
we completely hyped them as major stars
we're gonna be using a lot of clips from
movies you've never seen essentially
those are in our universe the big box
office smashes and in between that we
have a lot of like really interesting
interviews with weirdos and things event
and it's just package like it's
Entertainment Tonight itself I think of
you also when we what do we would we
have to look forward to for season two
of your show my friend a lot of big guys
Vivica Fox
what well be please Questlove fee pay
and t-pain currency what's this Dominic
Monaghan
so is it HD this season looks and it's
way better starting up I told the tenth
possibly possibly no / yes arch over
October 10 do you guys I don't know if
you heard about this we had this robot
downstairs
yes asking about I mean apparently it's
a big fan of the show and kind of wanted
to meet you guys we - that that is
impossible I kicked that robot says yeah
okay that's right
I don't know I don't know if he's
programmed for that we can go find out
I'll kick that robot that alright it's
gonna be handled versus the robot what's
hot what's trending with electronics
yeah what's going on
make something up over walking
no we've nowhere to go we've nothing to
do please no please and then we all
disappear